so
okay
so uh yeah i'm gonna talk about uh you
know all this stuff and let me just uh
review what we did in the last two
lectures
uh so these lectures are about grass
classification in the first lecture
we proved that every weighted undirected
graph has a weighted sub graph h with n
log n over epsilon squared edges so
these laplacian quadratic forms are one
plus epsilon uh close
and this was achieved by you know a
random sampling algorithm where you
sample the probability of proportional
to its effective resistance
and the way we derived the algorithm was
really by converting this into a linear
algebra problem where we turned each
graph into a bunch of vectors which are
uh you know decomposing the identity and
then we sample them according to their
squared norms this turned out to be the
effective responses
but then uh you know this was not uh
this is sort of pretty it's not clear
this is optimal because this log factor
so in the second lecture i showed you
how to improve this bound to 4n over
epsilon squared
so you get rid of the log n
and this is by a deterministic greedy
algorithm that's based on adding one
edge at a time which corresponds to rank
1 updates of these matrices
and the way we did this is that we you
know sort of uh figured out a way to see
what these random updates do to the
eigenvalues in terms of some sort of
repelling electrical charge model and
then we had this barrier function that
we used to you know analyze how these
eigenvalues behave and guide the choice
of the next edge
and well there was some deterministic
algorithm without this now
so the thing is that this is still not
really the end of the story because this
bound is 4n over epsilon squared and the
graphs that we produce are weighted
undirected graphs
so in particular if i apply this to the
complete graph on n vertices
i get a weighted
graph with 4n over epsilon squared edges
which is this kind of approximation
but i actually but i actually know that
for the complete graph the correct
answer is 2n over epsilon squared and i
don't actually need these variable
weights right so remember this example
that i showed you in the beginning
like the first example of
specification if you take the complete
graph and you take d random matchings
uh where d is two over epsilon squared
then with high probability
you know when you rewrite the edges by n
over d this thing is a one plus epsilon
approximation
um and
uh you know since the complete graph has
eigenvalues all equal to n this is just
saying that the eigenvalues of this
random graph lie between n times one
minus one and n times uh one plus
epsilon
and you know since all the weights are
the same they're all n over d this is
you should really think this is an
unweighted graph so in particular if i
scale the weights back to one then i
just scale the eigenvalues down
by a factor of d over n
and the statement of you know the bottom
of this is really that if you take d
random unweighted matchings then the
eigenvalues are between d times one plus
one plus plus epsilon
and actually if you actually
you know care about the second order
terms the precise statement is this this
was proven by friedman
uh this is a it's a very difficult thing
to prove that if you take d random
matchings the eigenvalues are between d
minus two square root of t minus one and
d plus two square d minus one plus some
little of one factor
all right
so this was the you know this is the the
precise statement for what happens when
you take the random matchings
and this is better than what we were
able to produce because it's uh because
it's it's a it's a regular graph
um so
i mean we didn't guarantee anything like
that in the things that we constructed
and it's unweighted and it has this
better bump
so now the question is you know uh can
you can you get this this kind of exact
pound without weights
okay so that's what i'm going to talk
about today how to get a regular
unweighted parts for the complete
graphics bounds
and you know why am i beating this
complete graph to death like why do i
care so much about as far as far as the
complete graph well you know unweighted
approximations of the complete graph are
also called expander graphs which you've
heard luka talk a lot about and you know
uh they're sparse well-connected graphs
which are these two properties that are
you know it's kind of difficult to get
them at the same time and they behave
like random graphs you know
all the all the edges have all the cuts
have lots of edges leaving random walks
mixed quickly etc and they're sort of a
very useful general pseudorandom object
in computer science that are used all
over the place
so
so now in this talk i'm going to talk
about adjacency matrices so so far i've
been talking about laplacians but it's
going to turn out to be more convenient
to talk about adjacency matrices for
this particular case of the problem
and this is not a big deal because if
you have a deregular graph then the
laplacian is just d times the identity
minus the adjacency matrix right
so
uh you know i'm going to talk about
adjacency matrices they have real
eigenvalues and the eigenvalues are just
d minus the eigenvalues of the laplacian
and let me just review some really basic
facts about these adjacency matrix
eigenvalues which you also heard from
luca so if the graph is deregular then
the top eigenvalue is equal to d that's
easy to check if you plug in all ones
vector here because the row sums are
equal to d you just get that's all one
vector is an eigenvector with eigenvalue
and
it's also not difficult to see that if
the graph is by far tight then the
eigenvalues are symmetric about zero so
if lambda is an eigenvalue minus lambda
loss of an ending value
and these two facts are completely
general and they hold for
all graphs so i'm going to call these
trivial eigenvalues because they're
well they don't tell you anything about
the graph
okay so you know with this uh
the jz matrix definition of expander is
is the following it's a good expander of
all the non-trivial eigenvalues are
small
so you have these two eigenvalues of d
and possibly minus d i want everything
else to be close to zero
so instead of talking about
approximating the complete graph i'm
going to talk about all the eigenvalues
being close to zero which is the same
thing
and for example here are some you know
really good expanders according to this
definition if you take the complete
graph on the vertices of the complete
bipartite graph then all their
non-intervals are actually equal to zero
so you know the best
but really what we want to do is
construct an infinite family of such
graphs we don't just want to do it for
some fixed finite and we want to be able
to do this for some n going to infinity
or keeping d fixed
and it's not possible to construct an
infinite sequence of graphs for which
all the non-trivial values are equal to
zero
in fact there's a there's a limit to how
well you can do this this was shown by
elon papa in 1986
that for any infinite sequence of graphs
you cannot make the eigenvalues
concentrate in any interval that's
smaller than this minus two squared d
minus one to two square t minus one okay
you cannot get better eigenvalue
concentration than in this interval
and uh you might be wondering what this
number is and this number has a meaning
it comes from a particular object the
infinite dra tree so this is an infinite
graph which is well it's a tree where
the branching factor is equal to d
an infinite graph uh it turns out if you
write down it's a density matrix in
computed spectrum which which you can do
uh it's literally equal to this interval
minus 2 square d minus 1 to 2 square t
minus one and so the content of content
of alarm blocks theorem is that
this graph is the best possible
irregular expander from a spectral point
of view the theorem just says that
you know the best graph is this infinite
graph and this is uh this is how good it
is
so the goal is to
get the same bound for finite graphs
okay and that gives us the definition of
aromas and graphs so a ramanujan graph
is called a gram is called roboration if
all of its non-trivial eigenvalues have
absolute value at most two squared d by
four
so
it says it's as good as spectral
expander as the infinite irregular tree
and uh i already told you that if you
take a random irregular graph graphs
union of d matching it's pretty close
so it has eigenvalues 2 squared d minus
1 plus little over 1. so it's not
actually a romanism graph according to
this definition
because it doesn't actually match the
behavior of this tree
but it gets pretty close
but then importantly there's this you
know amazing uh independent results of
margulis and lubatsky philip sarnak who
showed that when d is equal to p plus
one or p is a prime there are infinite
sequences of vomiting graphs which are
deregular and these graphs were kaley
graphs
they were the proof of this uses some
deep number theoretic results
but this is a really explicit
construction and has proved to be useful
in computer
science uh so
so this is very nice and it leaves open
this sort of funny question that what if
d is not equal to prime plus one
okay so uh so some so it turns out you
can do it for d equal to prime power
plus 1 that's due to morgan's turn
but it was actually not known uh whether
these things exist for d naught equal to
prime plus one
and sort of the conceptual point here is
do these things exist because of number
theory or do they exist for some generic
reason
so what i'm going to tell you about
today is a resolution of this
question in the bipartite case so the
main theorem is the serum with marcus
and spielman
it says that uh when d is greater than
or equal to three there's an infinite
family of bipartite ominous in terms so
bipartite means it has trivial
eigenvalues of d and minus d
and the theorem states that there's for
every d there's an infinite sequence for
the other eigenvalues are two squared t
minus one what happens if you i know
people do experiments if you take a
random irregular graph which activates
we don't know
there's there are various bets going on
above
what is the probability that's fantastic
questions definitely cannot be they
definitely bound away from one
that's not proof i think
no no no no no i'm not asking anything
about proofs only about what's what's
the observed just you know
can you keep finding that
can you tell us what the discussion is
about
oh oh so the the discussion is if you
take a random graph what's the
probability that it's rare
is
i
think it's so much super multitude
about the distribution there's a
connector that the distribution is tracy
widow which is the same as the
distribution of the largest
psychological gaussian matrix which
would give you a number
um
okay so that's the theorem
and the proof is uh not based on number
theory it's a complete elementary and
i'll show you the proof today
and there's one major uh you know
caveat here which is that this is an
existence proof it does not give you a
way to explicitly construct these
objects so it's not useful for
algorithms or anything like that
and it's based on something called the
interlacing families of polynomials and
if you went to the last talk this is
this whole dream sequence with the
expected polynomials it's a actual way
to prove something using expected
characteristics
okay
so the way we do this is we prove we
follow an approach given by boohoo and
linear
and
so you know what we want to do we want
to construct an infinite sequence of
deregular graphs with a spectrum that's
concentrated
so to do that it would suffice to find
some operation
which doubles the size of a graph
without blowing up its eigenvalues too
much
so what i would like to happen is sort
of in this picture suppose i have a
graph suppose it's romanism so the
eigenvalues are this interval i want to
find some operation which gives me a
graph on twice as many nodes and maybe
this adds some new eigenvalues or moves
x values a lot so it doubles the number
of eigenvalues but i want to find an
operation so these new eigenvalues also
align the interval
and if i can do this then certainly i
can just keep iterating this and get an
infinite sequence
so bill and daniel gave a very nice
operation uh
which you know which is uh
well which is which the conductor has
this property so it's called a two lift
which is the same thing as a two cover
so so so let me define what a two lift
is so suppose i have a graph on n
vertices uh which i'm going to call the
base graph
so the two lift is a graph on two end
vertices and it's obtained as follows so
first you make two copies of the
original graph you get the two inverses
and i have two disconnected copies okay
and now what you do is uh oh yeah so
there are two copies and you know and
each vertex has
as you know a0 and a1 so each each node
now has two copies
now you do is you look at each edge
and uh
you so so if i look at this edge c
naught uh if i look at the edge c d now
there are two copies c naught d naught
and c one d one
so you look at each edge and
right now the edges are parallel
you look at each edge and you either
leave it parallel or you cross the two
edges
so you make this binary decision for
each edge you either leave it as c
naught p naught c one d one or you cross
it to make it c naught d one d naught c
one
all right
so there are m edges in the base graph
you have to make m decisions so for
every edge you have to decide to leave
it parallel or not
the m decisions are two of them
possibilities they're two to the m
possible lifts of a given graph
and this thing that you get at the end
is called the lift graph
nodes and it's also deregulated
okay
so um
you know the the really nice thing about
uh
about two lifts is um
is that the eigenvalues of this two lift
are related in a very nice way to the
eigenvalues of the original graph
so uh
the first thing to note is that the
eigenvalues of the two uh
all of the eigenvalues of the original
graph are also eigenvalues of the two
lift so this is an easy exercise that
you can prove
that that you can uh it's a sort of
linear algebra
fact
um
but what's really nice about tulips is
that the new eigenvalues
of the two lift
can actually be described very
concretely
as follows so
given a true lift you associate the lift
with a signing of the adjacency matrix
right so you take the adjacency matrix
of the original graph
and for each edge that you cross
you turn the one into a minus one
so
for the original graph it's just a zero
one matrix
uh
in a two lift you have this you know
binary decision for each edge and
whenever you cross you you turn it into
a minus one keep maintaining something
so this is called the signing of the
adjacency matrix and as you can see it's
the same thing as the lift there's a
bijection between signings and
and now there's this very nice theorem
of below and lineal which shows that the
eigenvalues of the two lift
are literally the union of the old
eigenvalues and the eigenvalues of this
signed adjacency matrix
so if you want to know if you want to
reason about the spectrum of the tool
all you have to do is look at this
adjacency matrix that contains all the
information the scientific thing
and uh they made this really bold uh
conjecture in their paper which is that
every deregular graph has a two lift in
which all the new eigenvalues have
absolute value at most two square t
minus one
all right so
this is actually a conjecture about all
graphs so any graph it doesn't have to
be reunion
there exists a two lift whereas the new
eigenvalues meet this bound and well
because two loops are the same thing as
adjacency matrices what this means is
that every deregular density matrix a
that's just a zero one matrix with zero
the ones
that's just a zero and matrix with row
sums equal to d uh that every derivative
matrix has a signing so the norm of the
signing is at most two square t minus
that's a pure linear algebra conjecture
of matrices
and they proved that this is true uh
not with 2 square t minus 1 but with
this bound of square of b poly log b
which is also quite a good bound it's
very close to square root d
and by iterating this they constructed
expanders with
eigenvalues contained in this interval
so what we did is we proved
this conjecture for bipartite graphs
that if you have a bipartite graph
there's a signing of the adjacency
matrix for which the normal designing is
and this bipartite just comes in in a
very uh
simple way
so recall that i said that um
uh
okay so so it comes in as follows so
theorem we actually prove is this
every d regular dnc matrix has a signing
since it's the largest eigenvalue of the
signing that most two squared d minus
one so this is the maximum eigenvalue
it's not the maximum absolute value of
the eigenvalue so we only control the
top eigenvalue we don't control the
bottom line
but then recall you know what i said
earlier the eigenvalues of bipartite
graphs are symmetric about zero
so if it's bipartite if you control the
top i can all you automatically get the
bottom one for free
so you know our weaker theorem
for bipartite graphs implies that the
norm is implies that the absolute values
are bounded which is that's the only way
bipartite just comes into this argument
and you can check that you know taking a
lift preserved by particles so
this is enough to do the construction
report
okay so so let me tell you how to prove
this theorem so
you know the task is pretty simple
you're given a adjacency matrix you need
to find the signing with small norm
so you know one natural idea is to
choose the signing randomly so just for
every edge or with probability half make
it plus one probably has like a minus
one
and uh unfortunately if you do this then
uh it appears that the expected uh norm
of the signing well the expected norm is
strictly bigger than two squared d minus
one
so in expectation certainly uh this
thing is not revolution
uh
it's not awful so bill and lineal showed
that if the base graph is nearly wrong
expectation
is order square would be followed by v
so it's not way off
but it's definitely not going to get you
this bond so random signing is not going
to work it's not
it's not something uh i mean it's okay
i'm not gonna say it's rare but it's
something you have to look for at least
a little bit
okay so what do we do instead so uh the
you know sort of the main novelty in
this approach is to
uh study the roots of this uh
of this signed adjacency matrix to study
the roots of
this of any matrix by looking at looking
at it through the characteristic model
so what i'm interested in is the largest
eigenvalue of a sub s which is my
significance matrix
so observe that this is the largest root
of chi of a sub s which i'm going to use
to denote the characteristic polynomial
base of s which is just determinant of x
i minus a sub s
all right so
this is just it's a linear algebra fact
the eigenvalues are the same as the
roots of the characteristic polynomial
and the main idea is to look at this
object the expected characteristic
polynomial of a random signing of the
addition
so you give me a matrix i
look at all possible signings for each
one i get a polynomial i literally
average these polynomials
and uh
this is
i mean this is literally what it looks
like it's a coefficient wise average of
the polynomials so this a priori is a
little bit weird because what i wrote up
here you know what i'm really interested
is the roots of these polynomials right
and this averaging i'm averaging the
coefficients of the polynomials and the
relation between roots and coefficients
is you know
non-linear certainly so
uh
i mean something in general very
mysterious things can happen when you
just have just average photo
so the punchline is that the polynomials
here have some very special structure
which we call interlacing family
uh which indic which uh um
implies the following uh fact that
there exists uh that uh if i take the
expected characteristic polynomial over
random signing
there exists a
specific signing a single signing s so
the largest eigenvalue of the
characteristic polynomial of that
signing is at most the largest
largest root of the expected
characteristic
all right so i'm able to compare
this funny object that i got by
averaging coefficients i'm able to
compare its roots to the roots of the
individual polynomials
okay so so you know this is the main
device in the proof and given that this
is how i'm going to proceed there's a
sort of clear three-step line to proving
this theorem
so the first is to prove what i just
claimed that there exists some
polynomial in this collection which does
as well as the expected characteristic
formula i just want to reiterate that
this is
very different from the usual kind of
averaging argument where you would say
that there exists a polynomial whose
largest order is that mostly expected
larger so that's a trivial statement
right
the key is a pair of taking the
expectation inside the largest group
operator but this is very different from
uh just the usual argument
okay so once i can do that i now need to
figure out what the expected polynomial
is so in the second step i'm going to
calculate the expected polynomial and
the expected polynomial turns out to be
an object which is very well studied in
algebraic graph theory called matching
polynomial
and the third step is to show that the
expected polynomial's largest root is
what i want it to be right so
this also it turns out to be exactly
what i want two square t minus one and
this is also due to some classical uh
uh let's do some uh work in statistical
physics which i'll tell you about
um
but once i can do these things i'm done
right together these three things imply
there exists a signing whose largest
uh root is two squared d minus one which
proves uh biblio and vanilla's
conjecture
so let me start with actually parts uh
two and three because uh well because
they've already been done it turns out
and uh and they'll tell you that it's
worth trying to do part one
so let's calculate the expected
polynomial
so after you're ready this could be
anything right even though the
individual polynomials are real roots
i'm adding exponentially many of these
polynomials this polynomial may not even
have real roots right it could be
anything
so it turns out gods and government have
already looked at this 30 years ago
and what they showed is that for any
graph g if you look at the expected
characteristic polynomial of a random
signing of the if it's adjacency matrix
you get the matching polynomial of the
graph
so let me tell you what the magic
polynomial is
uh it's a univariate polynomial it's a
degree n if the graph has n nodes and
it's a generating function which counts
the number of matchings of various sizes
in the graph
so the matching polynomial of graph g on
nodes uh the coefficient of x to the n
minus 2i is the number of matchings of
the i edges
all right
so here's an example of what this looks
like here's a graph and here's its
matching polynomial it's a six vertex
graph it's a degree six polynomial
and uh well there's one matching with
zero edges uh
there are seven matchings with one edge
because there are seven edges in the
graph
there are 11 matchings with two edges
and there are two perfect matchings
so
that's it i just spread compute these
numbers and i get this polynomial
and this uh
yeah so you can see for example the
constant term of this polynomial just
counts the number of perfect matchings
which is something like
that
so that's a matching polynomial
and uh the theorem is that the expected
characteristic polynomial random signing
over jason matrix is equal to this and
here's the proof or here's here's a very
simple food
so the proof is just to expand this
expression
using permutation right it's an
expectation of a determinant of x i
minus a sub s
where
x i minus a sub s is a random matrix
that looks like this so it has x's on
the diagonal
and it has random plus minus one
variables on the off uh off diagonal i
don't know
on the rest of the entries which
correspond to edges and uh
you have for every edge you actually
have two entries which are going to get
the same value
but apart from that the iid
so all the signs are plus minus one id
okay so so here's the proof right so you
expand the determiner using permutations
right the terminal is the sum of
products over permutations of the
entries
so let's look at let's look at the
contribution from different permutations
so suppose here's a permutation suppose
i have a permutation that that includes
any zero entries well i get zero because
it's a product
and if i get it if i have a permutation
that only takes one entry for any one of
the edges i also get zero
because uh it's an it's an expectation
of this entry it's an expectation of
this product and these entries are
independent and the expectation of each
of these entries is zero so if i just
get one term coming from any edge i get
zero
so the only terms that survive
consist of terms on the diagonal and uh
both entries
uh for particular edges
uh but these just correspond to swaps
if
you're thinking about permutations
uh so yeah so so the only permutations
that are nonzero are these involutions
and these are just matchings
these are literally just matchings in
the graph
and well you can calculate you see that
if you compute the expectation of a term
like this you get a square of this which
is one so you're just constantly
remembering that's the proof
you just expand the imperfections
okay so we know what the expected
polynomial is it's a it's the matching
point
okay so is that is that a good thing
turns out it's a really great thing so
this matching polynomial was uh defined
and looked at 40 years ago by how many
weed
in 1972 in the context of statistical
physics
and they proved first of all the roots
are real
so that's also not obvious right if i
just write down some generating function
uh the roots can be anything so they
prove that the roots are real
and the roots are absolute value at most
2 square t minus 1
right so that's exactly the number that
we need
now the proof you know at this point
there are a bunch of ways to prove this
so they proved it using
basically by writing down a recurrence
for this polynomial uh
like what happens with this polynomial
when you do either vertex or delete an
edge and by studying this recurrence
they could well quite elementarily in
less than a page but it takes some care
they could prove that the roots are most
referred to
but there's also a very nice sort of
more conceptual proof due to godzilla
which is in his book on algebraic craft
theory
which gets the same bound and gets it
from this infinite irregular tree
so roughly speaking what god sells proof
does
is what godzilla shows is that this
matching polynomial
divides as a polynomial the
characteristic polynomial of a certain
tree obtained from the graph by looking
at paths basically
by uh so a certain large tree obtained
from the graph called the path tree
so godzilla proves that this thing
divides the characteristic column of the
path tree the path three is a tree
whose whose degree is bounded by d so
it's an induced subgraph of the infinite
irregular tree
and that's
that's a connection
so this number really comes from this
infinity
um
so so that's great so the
largest root of the expected polynomial
which is imagine polynomial is exactly
what we want
and so all we have to do is show the
first part that there exists some
polynomial that does as well as is
expected
now the uh
yeah so this turns out to be implied by
the statement that this collection of
polynomials in interlacing family but
basically you know what we need to do
here we need to understand what
averaging polynomials does to the roots
of the polynomial right so we're
interested in the roots but we're
averaging the coefficients we need to
understand how these things affect each
other
so
you know
the most vanilla
question that we need to answer
is the following suppose i have two
polynomials and suppose they have real
roots
uh and suppose i compute their average
which is this expectation so when are
the roots of the individual polynomials
nicely related in some way to the roots
of the expected formula the average
color from them
so in general things can go quite wrong
so here's a canonical bad example
the polynomials are x minus 1 squared
and x plus 1 squared so they're
quadratics they have real roots clearly
and clearly when you add them you get a
sum of squares so you get something
that's just positive it doesn't even
have real roots
so adding real root of polynomials does
not preserve real roots let alone the
locations of the roots
and this is not some you know degenerate
situation with multiplicities this is
typically what happens if i take two
polynomials i carry some polynomials
roots one two three four and i average
them i get something with you know weird
looking so
typically when you average real world
polynomials you'll get things that have
well not even real groups
uh but there's some examples where
something could happen so here's a
canonical example
where something really nice happens
so suppose the polynomials are again
quadratics but they're moved so their
roots alternate as shown in this picture
so the roots are 1 3 and 2 4.
so then if you calculate the average
which is this purple polynomial
you'll see that each root of the average
polynomial lies in the convex hull of
the corresponding roots of the
individual polynomials
so the roots of the average end up being
some kind of averages of the roots not
with the same distribution but they end
up lying in convex houses
so in particular they're real but we
also know where they are so this is
great and this is what this is what we
would like to
exploit
so uh
you know
you know the main you know concept in
this in this proof is that there's a
sufficient condition that tells you when
this happens so if you have some
polynomials that you want to average and
you want to say the roots of the average
or in the convex houses roots of the
individual polynomials there's a nice
sufficient condition and the condition
is called common interlacing
so uh so what's a common interlacing so
i already told you what interlacing is
yesterday but let me just write down the
reference again so polynomial of degree
n minus 1 it relates to the polynomial
of degree n if the roots
alternate as shown in this picture this
definition also works for two
polynomials of degree n
in
the obvious way
so that's the definition of interlacing
and i'm going to say that two
polynomials or a family of polynomials
have a common interlacing if there's a
single you know third polynomial
that interlaces all of them
okay
so uh
so this
actually this allows you to prove this
very simple and useful theorem
which is the following if you have two
polynomials p naught and p one
which are real rooted and manic i guess
i should have written that to the
harmonic and
if you have two polynomials that have a
common interlacing
then
the largest root of one of them is at
most the largest root of the average
all right
and the proof of this theorem is really
simple i'll just show it to you on the
slide
so here's the proof so here are my two
polynomials p naught and three one
they're cubics they're harmonic
and they're real groups
so what i've assumed is that they have a
common interlacing which is a quadratic
polynomial which interfaces both of them
so the roots of the quadratic look
something like this there are these
stars alpha 1 and alpha 2.
and
the roots of the common interlacing
split the real line into three intervals
right three intervals
and
each interval contains exactly one root
of each of my individual polynomials
that's what it means to have a common
interval
each of these intervals has exactly one
red root and one blue group
so let me look at uh these intervals and
let me you know shrink these intervals
so their endpoints are now
uh
actually roots of these polynomials so
to shrink them so they're snug up
against sort of these roots
and i'm interested in the largest root
right so let's look at the largest
interval
so observe that to the right of this
interval both polynomials are strictly
positive that's just because the
polynomial is modified so it goes to
infinity as
x goes to infinity
however i know that each polynomial has
exactly one root inside this interval so
it changes sign exactly once inside this
interval so what that means is at the
beginning of the interval
each polynomial has to be non-positive
because it changed sign right
so that means that the in particular any
average of these two polynomials has to
be positive to the right of the interval
and negative
at the beginning of the interval
so because it's a continuous function it
means it has to be 0 somewhere inside
the integral of the expected polynomial
and then in particular
the the bottom the root at the bottom of
this interval which is the root of the
red polynomial is that most of the
largest sort of the expected pronoun
so i just i find that the root of the
expected polynomial inside this interval
by this operating argument and that
shows me it's at least you know
the least largest root of the individual
so that's that's literally the proof
uh so
um okay so you know this sounds very uh
simple but
this is this is this is all we need to
reason about these averages uh
well okay it's not all we need but this
is this is this is sort of the main
thing
okay so so this observation by itself is
yes
so this this condition that you have a
common interest in seems kind of strong
and i was wondering if you could weaken
it to get the same conclusion uh
yeah you can so
this so if you only care about the
largest rule you actually just need one
guy here you just need some you need
some interval where these guys change
sign exactly once you don't need all of
them
this actually implies something much
stronger that the kf root of the average
is contained in the
context of the case roots of the
individual polynomials
what it turns out that so this weaker
condition is fine but there's no
systematic way to prove it
whereas there turns out to be a very
nice systematic way to prove existence
of common interactions which i'll get to
in a moment
and can't you control the last uh roots
using the same thing by considering the
last interval
yeah so the problem with this averaging
argument is that it only gives you one
root at a time right
yeah so i mean this doesn't prove that
there's a single polynomial whose
largest root is less yeah so if i want
both of those things then
yeah it's actually more true
yeah it's also false
that's true yeah the argument doesn't
give it and it's false there are easy
examples where
you have distributions or it's just
false
if they're not if you're not interfacing
you have to get a conflict
no no no so there are examples where
this is not only a condition for real
rootedness there are examples where you
can add polynomials without a common
interlacing and have real roots
and they're in the right place but
or they're not in the right place if you
want any linear combination of your
polynomial a couple of real roots then
they watch them release each other yeah
that's what i'm going to get to so i'm
going to get to that in a few slides
exactly
any conference coming
okay
um
okay so that's the fear of our
confidentializing
and this uh so this is useful if you
have a bunch of polynomials that have a
common interlacing we have exponentially
many polynomials one for every signing
of the adjacency matrix and they don't
have a common influence it's a very
large collection polynomials
so instead we have this uh
you know method for inductively applying
the theorem on the previous slide which
we call interlacing family of
polynomials so this is just it's just a
device for systematically applying this
uh
this common interlacing observation
inductively so
so here's the definition so i have a set
of polynomials p sub s indexed by
zero one to the m so for example index
five
uh signings of graph on dimensions
so it's an interlacing family if you can
place it on the leaves of a binary tree
uh
oh yeah so generally family if they all
have real roots on harmonic first of all
although individual polynomials are real
roots in our mind you can put them on
the roots of a tree
and then you can define the
polynomials on the internal nodes to be
the sum of the polynomials in subtree
all right so here are my original
polynomials
and if i look if i go one level up i
have p naught which is the average of p
naught naught and p naught one
and p one is the average of p one not
two and one so the internal nodes are
just indexed by
uh initial segments of these bit strings
okay and then the root is just the
average the root is just the sum of all
the numbers
so this is the definition of this tree
the nodes are indexed by polynomials
um and you should just think of the
internal nodes as you think of the root
as being the expectation of all the
polynomials and the internal nodes as
being conditional expectations
conditions not some of the things
so if you have such a tree
and um
every pair of siblings has a common
interlacing then we call that an inner
basic family
okay so
every node that i look at i want the the
the two polynomials that are to sum up
to have a column into it
okay and then this gives a very easy
theorem by induction if you have
something that's an interlacing family
then there exists a particular leaf
there exists a particular polynomial in
the family whose largest group is the
most large root of the
root
of the tree
so uh and the proof of this is just
induction right so you started the rule
and now i know that it's too uh
children p naught and p one have a
common integration
so that means the largest root of one of
them is at most largest root of
the root right
and now again i i i get some
some polynomial again it's two it's two
extensions have a common interfacing one
of them does at least as well as that
polynomial i just follow this out two
weeks
so this is also i mean this is a trivial
induction argument it's also called a
method of pessimistic estimators
so that's it so if you have if you're if
you have polynomials like this and all
these combinations do this you can find
you can you know set the bits one by one
so instead of trying to do it in one
shot you you find this thing by setting
these up
and what we prove is that getting back
to our situation if you look at the
family of polynomials indexed by
signings of a graph findings of the
daisy matrix that is an irreleasing
factor
and that will prove the first part
okay so how do we prove this theorem
well looking at the definition you need
to prove that a whole bunch of common
interlacings exist right
so
again the internal nodes i want to think
of them as conditional expectations so
the these are indexed by signings which
are big strings of like them the
internal nodes are indexed by partial
signings
which are uh bit strings of length k so
s one through square sign they've
already said
so the three is precisely the
the three of the signings yeah
yeah it's
it's the same thing i'm not sure why i'm
saying so many times but
um
and then the polynomials of these
internal nodes are just conditional
expectations
and what you need to do is find is find
the common interfacing for each one of
these internal nodes so you need to
prove that all these exponentially many
common releasings exist
and this seems kind of daunting where
you're going to pull these commoner
racings out of but well it turns out
there's this very nice characterization
which uh
due to fisk let's say uh but also it has
been known at least as far back as 1980
uh due to fel
uh
which says a confident existence of
common interlacing is the same thing as
certain real rooted miss statements
so so suppose so here's the the dilemma
suppose p and q are monica and real
rooted polynomials there exists a common
interlacing r of p if and only if all
convex combinations have groups so this
is exactly what you said earlier
um
and okay this is like a three line uh
proof so it's a good exercise you can
try to find this
um but it's it's really powerful because
it turns this existential statement into
a for all statements instead of trying
to pull this out of somewhere you now
have to verify a bunch of real words in
this statement so this sort of is also
why these weaker conditions are
as you were asking but this is this i
mean this is very this is a
very uh this makes it possible to prove
that these things exist
okay
so so we're going to use this to prove
that all of our common interlace things
that we would like
exist
um
and so what do you have to do well for
every internal node you need to prove
that every convex combination of its two
extensions
is real rooted
so there's some parameter lambda which
is this convex combination i need to
prove that given a partial sign in s1
whereas k
if i uh look at the convex nomination
lambda times
the extension with 1 plus 1 minus lambda
times the expansion of minus -1 then
this is related
and i'm now just going to observe that
this is
actually just a statement about an
expected characteristic polynomial over
all the polynomials but with a bias
distribution right
so this is this sort of uh obvious fact
that conditional expectations uh you
know conditioned on fixing s1 through xk
to be something that's the same thing as
just picking a distribution which is
deterministic on x1 and sk
and uh
and is random on the things that you've
not fixed
right so the polynomial i'm interested
in what does it do so s1 and sk s1
through sk are fixed
sk plus one
is plus one the probability lambda and
minus one probability one minus lambda
that comes from my convex combination
and the rest of them are just plus minus
1 with probability half
okay
you you seem to not uh christos
yeah so
the content of this is you can just
encode conditional expectations by
looking at biased distributions because
there's a product uh structure here
okay
because these signs are independent
that's important that the signs are
interesting
so in particular all of the common
interlacings that i wanted are implied
by the following single statement
that the expected characteristic
polynomial
is real rooted for every product
distribution on the entry list
so remember the matching polynomial
is the expected characteristic formula
the uniform distribution which is a
product distribution
but now suppose for each uh entry for
each
edge i assign a different bias could be
lambda could be you know deterministic
that gives me a different product
distribution i need to show that all of
these guys have real groups if i do this
then it implies that all the common
relations exist
and this is oh this is literally the
polynomial it's the average of the
characteristic polynomials with these
biases
where these can now be anything
and you can use this as a generalization
of how many leaves theorem so they
showed that this has real roots when all
the biases are
half or whatever all the probabilities
are half we need to do it for arbitrary
probability
okay so this is what we need to prove
and it turns out that to prove this so
to find you know the structure in these
polynomials that causes this to happen
it's useful
again to go back to laplacians in some
sense so i shifted to adjacency matrices
but now i'm going to go back to the
pluses
so
my expected polynomial is the expected
characteristic polynomial
is the expectation of p sub s under some
product distribution on sine x
well i want to show that has real roots
right i want to show this as real roots
real roots don't change and i shift
everything by d
so it suffices to show that the expected
pole expected a polynomial in x minus b
as real roots
and what is that that's the expected
determinant of x i minus d i minus a sub
x
so previously i just had a s here and
now i have
a d at here
and you know there's no signing here you
recognize this it's just a laplacian so
you should think of this as a sign with
laplacian
and
what is the point of doing this well
if i was just previously if you just
look at the adjacency matrix you can
write it as a sum of rank two matrices
times the sign signed variables s i j so
because each edge appears in two entries
you have this matrix is just the entry
that has a one and i j and one and they
have
you can write it as that matrix times a
plus minus one random variable right
but when you do this translation by d
you get this nice factorization into
outer products just like you do with the
laplacian remember that the opacity can
be factorized in terms of these outer
products one for every edge
and it turns out that the sine the
laplacian which is just the signing of
the sine of theta matrix shifted by d i
this also has the same factorization
so it has terms that look like delta i
minus delta
as delta transpose these are just my
incidence vectors for all the signs that
get a one
and then it has terms that look like
these incidence vectors over the plus
sign for all the signs we get minus
all right so for a random
signing
this is a sum of our products and which
outer product you get for every edge is
random it depends on which side is
stored
and now this is really uh sort of
okay oh yeah and it's important to
observe that this is well it's a sum of
rank one outer product so it's positive
side effects
so so this is a very special kind of
matrix
it's a sum of independent random random
matrices so this is this is the
structure that we really need to get our
hands on to uh
to prove to prove that this thing has
real roots once you do the shifting you
observe that this expected shifted
characteristic polynomial of a random
signing is the expected characteristic
polynomial the sum of independent random
rank one uh matrices so for every edge i
j you have a random vector v i j which
is in red and it's equal to
well either the incidence vector or the
incidence vector of the sine flip
depending on whatever the bias is so
it's a product distribution for every
edge of the bias
and now uh my polynomial of interest is
literally the expected characteristic
for some independent random
recommendations
and now uh we proved that all this is
the master sort of theorem we prove that
all such polynomials are real ones
so this is a big generalization so given
any independent random vectors v1
through vm which are in red
the ones i'm interested in came from
shifts of assigning but now any random
vectors
their expected characteristic polynomial
has real groups
so this in particular implies what i
want
and how would i prove this so it seems
you know sort of general that this
average could contain a lot of terms
so to do this we sort of follow this
philosophy which
has been around in statistical physics
for a while
which is that if you want to prove that
a univariate polynomial has real roots
uh often it's useful to look at and look
at it as a restriction of a multivariate
polynomial
so it's often easier to prove that
multivariate polynomials have real roots
i'll get to what that means in a moment
and
use that to deduce results by univariate
polynomials and the reason roughly
speaking is that uh
the space of transformations that
preserve multivariate real rootedness
which i'll describe in a moment is much
richer and more flexible than what you
get in the university
so this is what we're going to do so let
me tell you what a multivariate
real-would polynomial is so it's called
a real stable polynomial
and this is the definition of real
stability so suppose i have a polynomial
p and n variables that comes with
represent
it's real stable if every univariate
restriction in the strictly positive
portion
is is a real rooted
okay ignore this last line
so um
uh i mean there's a notion for
polynomials with complex coefficients
so um
so yeah so it's a real polynomial's real
coefficients
and uh if yeah it's real stable if all
restrictions in these positive
directions are rubrics the picture is
like this so here's a real stable
polynomial
and here's a restriction
in the positive author
and the point is that this should
intersect in exactly the right number of
places so let's say it's a degree four
this should have four roots for any line
that you look at okay so any any
restriction in the positive ortho you
should have all real roots
not saying anything about it
i'm sorry i'm sorry there's no f there's
a there's a p
you see this
yeah yeah i'm sorry there was some slide
attacking here that's right
so it's like okay
um
so the picture is this you take a this
is a binary polynomial its roots are
some sort of curves in the plane
uh and then uh you um
well uh i mean and then
when you look at these restrictions in
the positive ortho the real restriction
these should all intersect in the right
number of
places
and we don't care about what happens in
restrictions or other directions
so certainly a univariate polynomial
that's real stable is real rooted
because it has only one restriction
which is itself
okay so this turns out to be a really
great notion so
uh let me first show you an example of a
real stable polynomial which is a very
canonical useful example that comes up a
lot
it comes from determinants so this is
proved by roche and branded in 2008 but
i think it's been focused longer than
that
and what it says is if you have some psd
matrices a one through a k then the
determinant of some z i ai where z i are
the variables this is a real stable
polynomial
okay the proof of this is two lines and
i've written one of the lines here you
literally just write down what what a
restriction of this polynomial means
and you observe that it's always the
determinant of a uh it's always equal to
the characteristic or symmetric mean
you use this positivity condition to i
mean you can do this exercise it's uh i
skipped the one line but anyway okay
so
this comes down to the fact that
characteristic polynomials of symmetric
matrix of real groups
so this class of polynomial is always
real stable
now the really fabulous thing about real
stability is that it has a very well
characterized and strong closure
properties so the set of operations
which preserve real stability is really
rich well understood uh at this point
especially since the work of vorte and
brandon which
gives almost sort of a well gives a
characterization of operations
preserving stability
but okay we actually i'm sorry there's
some more slide hacking there's an
alternate definition of real stability
here it's the same thing
but
you can you can use this definition here
the universal restrictions are real
stable this is an alternate equivalent
okay anyway real stability is preserved
under many operations
and two of those operations are the
following one is setting any variable to
be a real number
all right
this also has like a three line proof if
you know complex analysis it has a
nice exercise
and
the other fact is that it's preserved
under certain differential operators so
if i take a real stable polynomial and
subtract off a partial derivative with
respect to any of the variables
this is still real stable
so this is a multivariate generalization
of the way i proved koshi's interlacing
theorem uh or maybe not exactly but it's
a it's a generalization of the fact i
told you yesterday that subtracting off
the derivative preserves real roots and
generates logarithmic polynomials here
also subtracting of a partial derivative
uh preservative stability the proof of
this is also basically the
gauss-seidel's theorem it's a variable
electron
so this was proved by lieutenant celica
in 1981.
so that's all we need
so i'm going to use these three facts to
prove that the expected characteristic
polynomial of any sum of independent
random variable matrices is rewarded
so the proof comes down to a formula it
comes down to
an identity which is this
okay so the whole proof is this identity
the identity says that suppose you have
v1 where we have independent random
vectors and their covariance matrices
are ai and the expected characteristic
polynomial of the sum of vivi transpose
is equal to this so what is this
so there's a determinant there's some
sort of multivariate characteristic or
it's a determinant of x i plus some
i so for every i every random vector i
now i have a variable z i
uh some z i ai where are the covariance
matrices so these are expectations of
the g principles
i look at this multivariate polynomial
then for each i i apply this
differential operator which subtracts
off the partial derivative with respect
to i
and i have m of these
right so i apply these m differential
operators
this gives me some n plus one variant
polynomial then i set all the extra
variables to zero that gives me a
univariate polynomial the identity says
that this is equal to the expected
characteristic formula
okay
now
this is um
you know it tells us many things so
first of all this is a sum over
exponentially many polynomials
here and sometimes what i've done is
i've taken the expectation inside right
the covariance matrix is the only place
where the expectation appears here
and if you know
a priori it wasn't even clear that this
is a function of the covariance matrices
but this tells you that that this
polynomial is a function of the
coherence
now the proof of this uh you know is
based on a single principle which is
something i also told you about
yesterday which is if you take a matrix
and add random rank one updates at a
random rank one matrix it corresponds to
subtracting alpha derivative of the
characteristic polynomial so that's
something i proved to you yesterday in
the context of specification but it
turns out to be
true here
also uh and
so this you can prove it half a page and
there's a very nice three line proof due
to james lee which i encourage you to
ask him about fine
but uh basically it's easier to prove
once you've decided to yes so yeah
adding independent random rank on
matrices
generates these differential operators
which gives you this representation of
this folder rank one is very important
to super false correct
actually you take the expectation
instead of the end yeah
well i mean in each step you sort of
take the expectation inside
the expectation turns into a
differential operator basically one way
to think of it is that these things let
you write a generating function for me
okay so once you have this that's it
that's pretty much it right so here's
the proof of the theorem this is a
determinant of some of psd matrices
which is real stable which i just told
you these differential operators
preserve real stability
setting things to zero for those rules
to code so this whole thing is real
stable but it's universal so it's real
okay so just the existence of this
formula that's the whole proof
but again this rank one structure is
what we're using
so once you have this you're done right
so i just showed you that any expected
characteristic volume of the sum of
independent random record makes you use
a real rule
a specific case of this is the expected
characteristic polynomial uh the shifted
expected characteristic column of a
random signing for any product
distribution of the signings and now you
see why i did the shifting to get the
right one structure
this implies that the expected
characteristic polynomial for any
product distribution itself is real
rooted
which implies that this is an
interlacing family
so everything has combinations which
implies that there exists a signing
which does as well as the expected
polynomial
which completes the proof here
okay oh yeah and which well which then
proves this conjecture and uh shows that
every graph has been left and you get an
infinity
okay so
you know the the point of this uh
this argument had essentially two uh
important components so
you know we used it to prove the
existence of a certain matrix right
and uh you know the interesting thing
here is that we reduced
some this combinatorial problem of
finding this matrix
to
analyzing some expected polynomial
proving that some polynomial has real
roots analyzing its roots this is an
analytic problem it's not a
combinatorial
and the first part where we needed we
proved real rootedness and interlacing
all these things we did this using very
generic facts such as the matrices of
rank one and this real stability theory
and the second part we did using mapping
polynomial
okay so i want to end by um
uh
just saying one more thing so
we've now figured out exactly what
happens with the complete bipartite
graph
but what if i wanted to get unweighted
as far as far as a general graph right
so this is not possible in general so
this is the example that i showed you in
the first talk which shows it's not
possible for the dumbbell graph you need
weights that are ordering and one
but what if i give you and yeah and then
the reason essentially is that this now
that you know about effective resistance
is the reason the reason is that the
edge in the middle is very high risk
but what if i gave you the hypercube
right so all the edges are equally
important in hypercube there's a lot of
symmetry there's no reason to expect
that you need weights
and nonetheless the theorems that i
showed you still produce weights
so turns out that you can
prove the following theorem
using techniques similar to what i just
told you about
you can prove that if all the edges in a
graph of resistance order n over n which
is the average resistance
then you can partition the graph into
unweighted sparsifiers each with n over
epsilon squared edges
so what it's saying is given the
hypercube which is analog and edges you
can partition it into log n graphs which
are literally just unweighted graphs
each of which is an approximation of the
original graph
and this is actually just a consequence
of uh all right okay i guess i guess i'm
out of time so i'll just go over this
quickly this is a consequence of the
following theorem which says if you have
any graphic boundaries resistance uh if
you have if you graph the bounded
resistances you can partition it into
two sub graphs
uh
such that the quality of approximation
is one plus alpha where alpha is the
bound on the resistances
and recursing on this produces this
particular unweighted specification
theorem
and this is a special case uh of some
theorem about decompositions of the
identity just as everything else i told
you about specification was this is a
special case of this theorem which has
given any decomposition of the identity
if the norms of the vectors are bounded
then you then there's an unweighted
partition into two sets each of which
approximates the whole so remember
previously i told you how to find a
weighted sparse subset which
approximates the original the original
set here it's literally a partition away
and the proof of this is based on
expected characteristic polynomials so
it's based on interlacing families and
the techniques that i just showed you
and this can also be used to prove a
bunch of other stuff
um so let me just uh quickly review what
i told you about so
the first is i showed you how to get
sparsifiers with n log n edges in nearly
linear time using effective resistances
and just viewing this graph of a bunch
of vectors
and then i showed you in the second talk
how to get order n edges but an end to
the fourth time so the algorithms are
getting more and more useless and this
is based on this electrical charges
model
and now i showed you this really useless
thing which is how to get
spotify's with no weights when it's
possible with order energies but in two
that time
by doing these random expected
polynomials
uh
and
yeah so i'm gonna send with open
questions okay so there are some obvious
ones i want to talk about today can you
do non-bipartite graphs so this always
works for my project graphs
uh it's not an algorithm and i said the
running time is currently 2 to the n
because computing these polynomials is
sharp pr so can you get an approximation
i think this is a very interesting
direction
um and then from yesterday's uh
talks there's you know there's a few
good questions left as well is there a
fast algorithm for this order and size
part this would actually be very useful
so people who actually use this have
emailed me on many occasions saying you
know they would they really want to get
rid of that log n
uh can you prove this to 2n over epsilon
squared i actually don't know right this
is not by factor of 2
and is there a fast combinatory
algorithm for resistance so yeah that's
it
i mean sometimes right like this use is
sort of like probably method and it's in
that sense simpler you're saying like
there exists an eigen a value which is
less than the second yeah
is there any situation where you can get
sort of a concentration bound in the
notice of families
so that's a really good question so i
think it's very interesting because
in general you cannot so in general
there are examples
where the things the good polynomials
are exponentially rare so i think a very
interesting question is to characterize
when this happens with high probability
and i think well it's related to
things like
well how much the random makes his
commute i think
that's right